احييكم مشاهدينا انا ميسون واهد واقدم لكم
اخبار الساعه كالعاده نبدا بابرز العناوين
مع هجمات اوكرانيا فاجنر تقر بخساره منطقه
في باخموس وانفصاليود
صعوبه الموقف
اشتباكات محتدمه في كتم والجنينه في
دارفور والسلطات المحليه تحذر من كارثه
بعد الفوز بالانتخابات تعيينات اردوغان
تكشف عن تراجع في سياسات اقتصاديه تسببت
في انهيار الليره
والاتحاد الاوروبي يحذر من خطوره سياسيه
للذكاء الاصطناعي ويتهم تويتر بعدم
التعاون
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
تصديها لهجوم اوكراني بري جديد في جنوب
دانيتس واكدت الدفاع الروسيه ان القوات
الاوكرانيه نفذت هجمات جديده في اتجاه
جنوب دانيتك من خلال اشراك ما يصل الى
ثلاث مجموعات تكتيكيه
[موسيقى]
اطول معركه في عمر الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا انتهت بالسيطره على بخمه تماما
لتستعد قوات فاغنر لتسليمها الى القوات
الروسيه وان انتهت المعركه الرئيسيه فصراع
السيطره على المدينه لم ينتهي فقد اكد
قائد القوات الاوكرانيه
واصمت عار بحق روسيا هكذا وصف قائد قوات
استعاده القوات الاوكرانيه لبلده برخيفكا
شمال بخموت والتي كان الكرملين اعلن
السيطره الكامله عليها في العشرين من مايو
الماضي ايضا زعيم الانفصاليين في دونيتسكي
يقول ان الوضع في باخمت اصبح اكثر صعوبه
كما استمرت الاشتباكات حول ضخمه بالرغم من
تراجع نسبي في حده القتال بحسب القوات
الاوكرانيه ايضا مشاهدينا الهجوم
الاوكرانيه المضاد الذي لم تعلن كياف عن
بدئه تؤكد موسكو انه
وانها تلمس اثاره على ارض الواقع في
اوكرانيا والداخل الروسي ايضا هذا الهجوم
يحتاج الى الدعم اللوجستي لتتمكن اكياف من
الاحاطه بكافه تكتيكات الهجوم وعلى راسها
طلعت الاستطلاعيه ولعل طلبها لمسيرات
فيكتور من المانيا هو جزء من خطتها غير
المعلنه 300 مسيره فيكتور استطلاعيه
طلبتها الدفاع الاوكرانيه من شركه كوانتون
سيستمز للصناعات الدفاعيه وهي المره
الثالثه التي تقدم فيها اوكرانيا على طلب
المسيرات حتى ان كاذ تلقت حتى الان
438 مسيره فيكتور جزء منها بدعم مالي من
الحكومه الالمانيه
مسيره فيكتور مسيره استطلاعيه تصنعها شركه
كوانتوم سيستمز للالمانيه المسيره لها
القدره على الطيران بين تضاريس القاسيه
بالاضافه الى عدم اصدار الضجيج ما يسمح
ببقائها متخفيه اثناء جمع المعلومات
ترسل تدفقات فيديو حتى 15 كيلومترا من
خلال قنوات امنه تستطيع الطيران نحو 180
دقيقه في المره الواحده
مزوده باجهزه استشعار كهروضوئيه واشعه تحت
الحمراء للكشف عن الاهداف
من بيتروس ينضم الينا دكتور مسلم شعيط
ورئيس المركز الثقافي الروسي العربي سيد
شايتو اهلا بكم معنا من يتحمل هذه الخساره
في بخموت بعد ان سيطرت عليها باجنر اليوم
تعترض بانها خسرت من ثقافي باخموت من
يتحمل المسؤوليه
مساء الخير الك وللمشاهدين اولا يجب ان
نتحقق من هذه المعلومات ليس هناك اي خساره
في منطقه ضخمه هناك هجوم اوكرانيا وهذا
الهجوم ولكن على لسان
السيد دكتور مسلم نعم يتحدث وينفع الكثيرا
واعتقد ان الهجوم هناك هو ياخذ طابع الكرو
والفار ولكن نتيجته تم دحر كل القوات
الاوكرانيه التي حاولت التقدم حتى يعني
حتى حتى يعني مسؤول الانفصاليين في دنيتك
هو اقر بانه الوضع صعب جدا
حكما هذا هجوم اوكراني يجهز له منذ اكثر
من سنه سيكون الوضع حساسا وصعبا عسكريا
لكن التقدم كان في منطقه خرسون لاحد
المراكز التي تركها الجيش الروسي ساعيا
لتفويق المجموعه التي تقدمت لكن الخسائر
التي تكبلوها في منطقه
دفعتهم الى الانكفاء ايضا الى الخلف من
حيث انطلقوا لكن نعم هناك نوع من الهجوم
الذي يشكل تقدما باتجاه الاراضي الروسيه
التي تحد الاراضي الاوكرانيه وتتعامل معهم
القوات الروسيه حكما هناك هذه هذا هجوم لا
يمكن الهجوم الا ان يكون فيه تقدم في
البدايه ومن ثم نتائجه تبدو واضحه بعد
فتره والمعركه ما زالت مستمره نعم خفت بعد
الظهر اليوم لانه بدا الهجوم يوم الاحد
البارحه اليوم اصبح قليل
يعني الاشتباكات في تحدي دا في منطقه ضخمه
دكتور هل يعني بانه روسيا اصبحت مقتنعه
بان هذا الهجوم المضاد الذي يحكي عنه منذ
اشهر لاوكرانيا قد بدا بالفعل
يعني روسيا تقول ان الهجوم بدا الاوكران
اذا حقق انجازا يكون الهجوم قد بدا عنده
ولكن اذا فشل سيقول انها مهمه استطلاع
وحتى الان هم مترددين يعني المسؤوله في في
وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه تقول بدانا ببعض
الهجمات
يتراجعت عن كلمه هجوم شامل كما كانوا
يعيدون به طب دكتور الم يحن الوقت يعني
اكثر من سنه على هذه العمليه العسكريه كما
سمتها روسيا على اساس انه ستكون خلال
اسابيع وتنتهي منها والان سنقترب من السنه
الثانيه
ولا شيء تحقق بالنسبه لروسيا الم يحن
الوقت بان يتم الاتخاذ القرار الجلوس
لمفاوضات مع الاوكران
اولا روسيا فعلا كانت تتوقع ان تكون هناك
عمليه سريعه تدفع السلطات في اوكرانيا
للتفاوض لم يحصل ذلك نتيجه للدعم الغربي
كما تلاحظون بوصل اكثر من مئه مليار دولار
مساعدات العسكريه والمرتزقه والخبراء
اضطرت روسيا لجوء الى الدفاع لكن هذا
الدفاع اتى على خلفيه تحقيق انجازات كبيره
منطقه خرسان ومنطقه والكثير منطقه لوغانس
ومنطقه التي تبقى منها القليل لتحرير هذه
الانجازات قامت بها روسيا بالاضافه الى ان
روسيا لم تنتقل الى الحرب في اوكرانيا حتى
الان هي تقوم بعمليه محدوده وتلجا الى
اسلوب اكتشاف كل ما يمكن استعماله الغرب
في هذه المعارك وهذا ما يدلل على ان روسيا
احيانا تتراجع فقط من اجل اكتشاف كيف يمكن
ان تقوم الدفاعات الروسيه بالعمل وكيف
يمكن ان تهاجم قوات الناتو باسلحتها
المتطوره فنحن امام عمليه
لا يمكن توصيفها بانها كلاسيكيه كما كان
يتوقع الكثير ان روسيا ستقوم بهجوم شامل
واسع بعد من سحبت من مناطق معينه في
اعذرني انتهى وقت المقابله من الدكتور
مسلم شعيطو رئيس المركز الثقافي الروسي
العربي
[موسيقى]
الى الشان السودانيه الان حيث توعد
الاتحاد الاوروبي بمحاسبه كافه المسؤولين
عن الانتهاكات والتجاوزات لحقوق الانسان
في السودان بعد رصد تجاوزات عده ميدانيه
وحتى الاتحاد الاوروبي في بيان طرفي
الصراع في السودان على وقت الاعمال
القتاليه على الفور وافساح المجال
لاستئناف عمليه انتقال سياسي شامله ذات
مصداقيه مضيفا ان العمل متواصل مع جميع
الجهات الاقليميه والدوليه المعنيه بما في
ذلك الاتحاد الافريقي والممثل الخاص
للامين العام للامم المتحده في السودان
لتحقيق تلك الاهداف
اعلن مسؤول حكومي في اقليم دارفور مقتل 23
فردا في معارك دارت يوم امس بمدينه كتم
شمال الاقليم واضاف المسؤول الحكومي ان
السلطات المحليه لم تعد قادره على تحمل
العبء الذي افرزته الحرب كما نشد المجتمع
الدولي لتقديم المساعدات الاغاثيه هذا
واكد المسؤول الحكومي في حديثه ان مدينه
الجنينه تشهد اوضاعا ماساويه ولا يمكن
احصاء عدد الضحايا
اكدت الامم المتحده في بيان لها ان الوضع
الراهن في الخرطوم وام درمان وبحري لا
يزال مصدر قلق كبير مع استمرار الاشتباكات
بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع مضيفه في
الوقت ذاته ان الاوضاع في غرب دارفور
ودارسيلا بوسط دارفور وكتم شمال دارفور
مستمره في التدهور الامر الذي اثر على
المدنيين بمن فيهم النساء والاطفال بعثه
الامم المتحده ذكرت ايضا ان مسؤولي حقوق
الانسان يتواصلون مع طرفي النزاع للدعوه
الى اتخاذ اجراءات ضد الجنات ولحمايه
المدنيين وممتلكاتهم
[موسيقى]
كشفت وسائل اعلام ليبيا نقلا عن عضو
اللجنه المشتركه 6 + 6 عز الدين قويرب عن
تاجيل التوقيع للاتفاق النهائي على قوانين
الانتخابات الذي كان مقررا اليوم الاثنين
في المغرب ليتم تاجيله الى يوم غد
الثلاثاء هذا ونسبت وسائل الاعلام الليبيه
حديثا عن عضو اللجنه عن البرلمان الليبي
ابو صلاح شلبي قوله ان اعضاء اللجنه وقعوا
الاتفاق ويرفضون تعديله
في اخبار الساعه سنتابع بعد قليل اردوغان
يعين المتحدث باسمه ابراهيم كالن في منسب
في منصب رئيس المخابرات خلفان
[موسيقى]
نعود لمتابعه اخبار الساعه اكد وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه
هي افضل طريقه لمنع ايران من الحصول على
السلاح النووي مشددا على انه في حال رفضت
ايران الخيارات الدبلوماسيه فان جميع
الخيارات مفتوحه
ما زلنا نعتقد ان الدبلوماسيه هي افضل
طريقه لمنع ايران من الحصول على سلاح نووي
بشكل يمكن التحقق منه وفعال ومستدام
وبالتوازي مع ذلك فان الضغط والرد على
الاقتصاديين يعززان دبلوماسيتنا اذا رفضت
ايرانو طريق الدبلوماسيه فعندئذ كما اوضح
الرئيس بايدن مرارا وتكرارا فان جميع
الخيارات مطروحه على الطاوله لضمان عدم
حصول ايران على اسلحه نوويه
قال المدير العام للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه رفايا الجروس ان مخزون ايران من
اليورانيوم المخصدر ارتفع باكثر من الربع
في ثلاثه اشهر موضحا ان مخزون ايران من
اليورانيوم المخصب بالنسبه 60% تجاوز
المئه كيلوغرام كما اشار غروسي الى انه
طرح مع الايرانيين نقطه اعاده تركيب
وتشغيل اجهزه المراقبه وامكانيه الوصول
الى البيانات
اقترحت مع الايرانيين نقطه اعاده تركيب
اجهزه الرقابه وامكانيه الوصول الى بيانات
هذه الاجهزه وفي حال عدم وصولنا الى
البيانات من اجهزه الرقابه لن نستطيع
متابعه عملنا فعندما قررت ايران الصيف
الماضي فصل اجهزه المراقبه والكاميرات ادى
ذلك الى وجود فجوه بيانيه لمده عام تقريبا
[موسيقى]
الى الشان التركي الان اعلن الرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان تعيينه مستشاره السابق
والمتحدث باسم رئاسه الجمهوريه رئيسا
للاستخبارات ياتي هذا التعيين بعد ان قرر
اردوغان تعيين رئيس الاستخبارات السابق
هاكان فيدان في منصب وزير الخارجيه وكان
فدان قال انه سيواصل العمل على تحسين
العلاقات الخارجيه لتركيا
تحول اقتصادي للرئيس التركي رضا الطيب
اردوغان في اعقاب الانتخابات التي سيطر
عليها عنوان الاقتصاد والازمات الماليه
المتتاليه ووعود جديده اطلقها وزير
الماليه محمد شمشك بالعوده الى سياسات
اقتصاديه وصفها بالعقلانيه بعد السياسات
المرهقه للاقتصاد التركي التي اتبعها
اردوغان وفق
اشار الى ضروره اعاده التضخم الى خانه
الاحاد على المدى المتوسط قرارات لم تطلق
من جانب احادي فيبدو ان الوعود التي
اطلقها وزير الماليه تمت بمباركه اردوغان
ليتخذ طريقا جديدا في معالجه الازمه
الماليه لكن تظل التساؤلات حول مدى مرونه
اردوغان لتغيير السياسات الاقتصاديه
للبلاد بحسب الصحيفه خبراء يرون ان اختيار
شمشك ليس مجرد تعيين رمزي بل خطوه للعوده
الى السياسات الاقتصاديه التقليديه ايضا
مشاهدينا تغيير كلي طال المسؤولين عن
القطاع المالي في تركيا فلم يكن محمد شمشك
التغيير الوحيد في اردوغان يفكر بتعيين
حفيظه غير اركان المديره التنفيذيه في
بنجوجمان سكس الامريكي كمحافظه للبنك
المركزي التركي بحسب مسؤولين اتراك وهي
واحده من المرشحين القلائل لخلافه رئيس
البنك الحالي شهاب وهو الرجل الذي قاد
السياسات غير التقليديه بخفض اسعار
الفائده وذلك من اجل محاربه التضخم لكن
السؤال كيف كان المنح الاقتصادي لاردوغان
بالرغم من ان تركيا حققت قفزات اقتصاديه
كبيره منذ عام 2002 بعد انهيار مالي في
التسعينيات واستطاعت لجمه تضخم الا ان
اردوغان لم يستمر على هذا النهج الاقتصادي
الذي بدا به
فاسرار الرئيس التركي على خفض اسعار
الفائده لتعزيز النمو الاقتصادي بينما
كانت الليره بامس الحاجه للدعم اضعف
رقبتها بنسبه 80% مقابل الدولار سلسله من
المسببات ارتبطت بسياسه اردوغان التي تسبح
عكس التيار الاقتصادي العالمي اوصل البلاد
الى تاكل القدره الشرائيه عند المواطن
وطبعا ارتفاع التضخم
ما الذي يواجه الاقتصاد التركي
انخفاض قيمه الليره التركيه
ضعف احتياطيات النقد الاجنبي
تمويل عمليه اعاده الاعمار افراز الزلزال
الذي ضرب البلاد
ارتفاع معدل التضخم
تاكل القدره الشرائيه
ما الذي يجب العمل عليه
تنفيذ سياسات الاصلاح
جذب الاستثمارات الخارجيه
رفع اسعار الفائده
من اسطنبول لا ينضم الي البحث والكاتب
السياسي في رضوان اوغلو استس فراس اهلا
بكم معنا كيف يمكن ان نفسر تعيين اردوغان
لشخصيات ستتبع السياسه لطالما هو كان
متمسكا بها
كانت الان ربما الليرات نوعا ما متوازنه
لكنها متراجعه كثيرا عما سبقت ايضا
استثمارات الخارجيه القادمه وجود السيد
محمد شمشيك اضافه الى بعض القواعد
الاقتصاديه الكبيره سيقودها السيد
فراس البعض يعتبر بانه سياسات اردوغان
وموضوع خفض الفائده هو كان سببا لابتعاد
المستثمرين عن تركيا ولكن السؤال هل قادر
سيد شمشك الان بسرعه بوقت قريب ان يجذب
مجددا هذه الاستثمارات لانه البعض يعتبر
بانه من الممكن في الايام القادمه او هذا
التعيين ينبا بانه موضوع الفائده سيتغير
ليس كما كان على ايام اردوغان والذي كان
متشبتا به
نعم هو نفسه قال يعني خلال سنه وعن الصف
او سنتين يعني يضع خطه مبدئيه ربما
لتماسك يعني اول البوادر الجيده هو ما
نشرته الصحيفه الرسميه قبل في الامس ان
التضخم في الشهر الماضي بالنسبه لتركيا
يعني اقل من عده سنوات سابقه وهذا يعني
صفر قال له صفر فاصله صفر اربعه وهذا يعني
على التراجعا لنسبه ممتازه جدا عن السنوات
والشهور للسنوات الماضيه اظن ان فقط وجوده
هذا مهم وايضا ما تفضلتم به
هل سيكون هناك رفع للفائده في الايام
المقبله
هذا احتمال يعني اظن هو احتمال لان حتى
الان اظن البنك المركزي واقف عن العمل
تقريبا في تركيا لديه اشكاليه ربما
الروتينيه فيها العمل الداخلي
والمخاطبه السيده جايه للقدوم الى البنك
المركزي وهو بنفسه
اقتراح الرئيس اردوغان باحضارها وهو حتى
قال عنها انها الفتاه المدهشه العظيمه ما
قامت فيه في عملها في البنك في من خلال
عملها
انا اظن هناك بوادر جيده هل سيرفعهم
مباشره ام لا انا اظن بمراحل تدريجيه يعني
هي امور اقتصاديه بحث لا استطيع ان اتكلم
فيها ليس تخصصي ولكن
ايضا هناك موضوع الفساد السياسات
الاقتصاديه كان هناك لون كبير عليها في
السنوات الماضيه لما الت اليه اللي ره
التركيه والوضع الاقتصادي بشكل عام ولكن
هناك نقطه اساسيه موضوع الفساد هل بهذه
التعيينات ايضا هناك مؤشر بانه سيكون هناك
سياسه قاسيه تجاه الفساد حتى يستطيع
الاقتصاد التركي النهوض مجددا
جل الوزراء الذين تم التعيينهم انا اراهم
انهم يستحقون ذلك نوعا ما تكنوقراط ونوع
ما هم مجتهدون وله حقيقيه حتى نائب الرئيس
هو متدرج كثيرا في العمل
الحكومي لذلك انا ارى ان هذه الوزاره فعلا
تبشر كل الوزراء طبعا يعني نوعا ما واضح
ان هناك تعيين كما الشعار الذي رفعه قبل
الانتخابات
اردوغان بانه قال الرجل المناسب والمكان
المناسب هذا هذا اظن مهم ايضا ليس فقط هذه
القضيه القضيه اخرى هي هناك وزارات لابد
ان ترتبط في بعضها يعني كما تفضلتي الامور
الاقتصاديه تحتاج الى كثير من الامور
العلاقه السياسيه الخارجيه ان تكون علاقات
ايضا جيده الاستثمارات جذبها ايضا مرتبط
بالسياسه ومرتبط في الامن كلما كانت
البلاد امنه اكثر كلما كانت يعني ايضا جذب
الاستثمارات مهم لذلك لاحظنا وزاره
الخارجيه وزاره الدفاع تقريبا النهج
الاردني اذا صح التعبير هم رجال السيد هكا
والسيد جلال رئيس الاركان وزاره الماليه
والاقتصاد لها نعم هو كان سابقا وزيرا
ولكنه لخلافه مع الرئيس اردوغان ترك
المنصب الان تمت مشاوره معه والعوده لهذه
الامور واذا استمر اظن سيكون له يعني ان
شاء الله سيكون له نجاحات ربما تتحقق
اضافه نقطه مهمه ربما
الوعد الذي وعدوا قبل الانتخابات رفع
المعاشات 40% والان بعد الانتخابات رفعها
اربعين بالمئه بمعنى ان ربما اقلل معاشات
ستصبح في 1000 دولار ويعادل 1000 دولار
انا اظن هذا ممتاز نوعا ما في المرحله
الحاليه
شكرا لك من اسطنبول الكاتب والباحث
السياسي فراس الرضوان
[موسيقى]
قال البيت الابيض ان الاجراءات التي
اتخذتها الصين في مضيق تايوان وجنوب بحر
الصين تعكس العدوانيه المتزايده من جانب
كين ياتي ذلك بعد ان نشرت البحريه
الامريكيه مقطع فيديو يظهر اقتراب سفينه
صينيه على مسافه 137 مترا من المدمر
الامريكيه في مضيق تايوان والتي اجبرت على
الابطاء لتجنب الاصطدام بالسفينه السينيه
دون ان تغير مسارها وصفات الولايات
المتحده ذلك بالمرور غير الامن
[موسيقى]
من جهته اتهم المتحدث باسم الخارجيه
الصينيه بين الجانب الامريكي بالتسبب في
المتاعب وخلق المشاكل في مضيق تايوان
تسبب الجانب الامريكي في المتاعب
والاستفزاز بينما تعامل الجانب الصيني
معها وفقا للقانون وكانت المبادره التي
اتخذها الجيش الصيني قانونيه واحترافيه
ويجب على الجانب الامريكي ان يفكر بعمق
ويصحح الاخطاء
[موسيقى]
نائب الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
رسميا اوراق الترشحه لخوض الانتخابات
التمهيديه داخل الحزب الجمهوري تمهيدا
لخوض سباق الرئاسه الامريكيه عام 24 وكان
بوقت سابق نيته الترشح عن الحزب الجمهوري
ليكون منافسا لرئيسه السابق ترامب كما من
المنتظر بحسب وسائل اعلام امريكيه ان ينشر
تفاصيل حملته خلال اليومين القادمين
يسارع عدد من الجمهوريين لاعلان الترشح
للرئاسه الامريكيه ترامب ما زال يتمتع
بالشعبيه الاكبر لدى الجمهوريين رغم ان
معارضين يبحثون امكانيه احباط مساعيه
نتابعه
يبدو الباب مفتوحا امام الجمهوريين لاطلاق
حملاتهم الانتخابيه والطموح الى ترشيح
الحزب لاحدهم في الانتخابات الرئاسيه وقد
تجمعوا في ولايه ايوا للتحدث الى الناخبين
بضيافه السنه الجمهوريه جوني ايرلز
سنسمع من مرشحين رئاسيين مميزين جدا
الغائب الاكبر كانت دونالد ترامب وهو
يتقدم على جميع المرشحين ويحظى بتاييد 50%
من الجمهوريين فيما يحظى حاكم فلوريدا
بمعدل 20% والاخرون لا يتعدى تاييد كل
واحد منهم الخمسه في المئه
هناك فرصه للتغيير وراي الناس سيتغير فتره
الان يحظى بشعبيه مبنيه على ولايته الاولى
في البيت الابيض
عمل اغلب المرشحين في ظل رئاسه او تحالف
معه لكنهم يطرحون انفسهم الان بدائل عنهم
وتجتهد المرشحه نيكي هيلي في القول انه
يجب البحث عن قياده جديده ما كان يجب ان
يحصل اي من هذا توفرت سنه كامله لبيدنج
ليمنع الحرب في اوكرانيا ولم يفعل شيئا
فيما يدخل مايكل السباق وهو يتهم دولار
ترامب بتعريض سلامته للخطر لدى اجتياح
مبنى الكونجرس في السادس من يناير 2021
علاقتنا لم تنتهي على خير وافترقنا بصداقه
اما الان فانظر الى المستقبل واقول ان
لدينا خيارات افضل
من الصدف الجيده ان بيتر رعف يعرف
منذ زمن طويل وقبل ان يكون نائبا في
الكونجرس مؤمن باسس ايمانه الغفران والكبر
مهمان جدا لديه ولا اعتقد انه يترشح لانه
يريد عرقله دونالد ترامب حاكم نيوجيرسي
السابق كريستي انسحب لصالح ترامب في العام
2016 لكن ترامب تخلى عن خدماته خلال
المرحله الانتقاليه
ويحتفظ كريستي بغضب ضد الرئيس السابق منذ
ذلك الحين مره جديده تبدو الانتخابات
الرئاسيه الامريكيه وكانها بشان ترامب فهو
يحتفظ باعلى شعبيه لدى الجمهوريه
والمرشحون الجدد يراهنون على تراجع هذه
الشعبيه مع بدء الانتخابات التمهيديه في
الغنم العربيه واشنطن
في اخبار الساعه سنتابع بعد قليل الاتحاد
الاوروبي يتهم تويتر باختيار المواجهه بعد
الانسحاب من مدونه للحد من مخاطر الذكاء
الاصطناعي
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد الى اخبار الساعه قد
تكون تقنيه الذكاء الاصطناعي الجديد قوه
من اجل الخير لكنها تحمل ايضا في طياتها
جوانب مظلمه الحديث لفيرا جروفا نائبه
رئيس المفوضيه الاوروبيه الاتحاد الاوروبي
طالب شركات التكنولوجيا الكبرى بتحذير
المستخدمين بشان المحتوى الذي يتم انشاؤه
بذكاء الاصطناعي والذي قد يؤدي الى
معلومات مضلله وتقول نائبه رئيسه المفوضيه
الاوروبيه ان الذكاء الاصطناعي تسبب
بتكوين مخاطر جديده وامكانيه حدوث عواقب
سلبيه على المجتمع بسبب تزييف المعلومات
واضافت ان شركات ميتا الملكه لفيسبوك
ومايكروسوفت والتيك توك عليها ان تتخذ
اجراءات بشان هذا الامر كما قال ان شركتي
مايكروسوفت وجوجلتين تضمنتا الذكاء
الاصطناعي في خدماتها عليها ضمان وعدم
استخدام هذه التقنيه في مواد خبيثه على حد
وصفها
يجب على الموقعين الذين يقومون بدمج
الذكاء الاصطناعي في خدماتهم مثل بورد
مايكروسوفت وضع الضمانات الضروريه التي لا
يمكن من خلالها استخدام هذه الخدمات من
قبل الجهات الخبيثه لتوليد معلومات مضلله
وثانيا الموقعون الذين لديهم خدمات ذات
امكانات لنشر المعلومات المضلله التي تم
انشاؤها بواسطه الذكاء الاصطناعي يجب ان
تضع بدورها تقنيه للتعرف على هذا المحتوى
وتسميته بوضوح للمستخدمين لقد قلت مرات
عديده ان المهمه الرئيسيه لدينا هي حمايه
حريه التعبير ولكن عندما يتعلق الامر
بانتاج الذكاء الاصطناعي فانني لا ارى اي
حق للالات في حريه التعبير
هذه السياسه مشاهدينا تواجه عائقا تحدثت
عنه المفوضيه الاوروبيه وهو رفض تويتر
الذي يملكه ايلون ماسك ان يوقع على مدونه
الاتحاد الاوروبي للحد من مخاطر الذكاء
الاصطناعي واشارت ان ماسك اختار بذلك
المواجهه بدلا من
التعاونزا لقد اختار تويتر الطريقه الصعب
اختار المواجهه من خلال الخروج من مدونه
ممارسات التضليل الاوروبيه الطبيعيه التي
تضع القواعد الاساسيه لقانون الاتحاد بشان
الخدمات الرقميه
اقل من ثلاثه اشهر امام تويتر للتغريد في
السماء الاوروبيه فقرروا المنصه بالخروج
من مدونه ممارسات التضليل للاتحاد
الاوروبي قد يفقدها احد ابرز جمهورها
ولاسيما انها تشكل ابرز منصات في تشكيل
الراي العام الاوروبي التفاصيل نتابعها في
التقرير التالي
قبل بضعه ايام وبتغريده من ثلاث كلمات
حذرت نائبه رئيس المفوضيه الاوروبيه للقيم
والشفافيه تويتر من الحظر في الاتحاد
الاوروبي قائله وداعا ايها الطائر تحذير
يبدو انه قريب من التطبيق بحق الطائر
الازرق
لقد اختار تويتر الطريقه الصعب اختار
المواجهه من خلال الخروج من مدونه ممارسات
التضليل الاوروبيه الطبيعيه التي تضع
القواعد الاساسيه لقانون الاتحاد بشان
الخدمات الرقميه المدونه التي اعلنت تويتر
نيته الانسحاب منها كان الاتحاد الاوروبي
قد اطلقها عام 2018 حيث ستدخل حيز التنفيذ
في الخامس والعشرين من اغسطس لاجبار
المنصات على مكافحه المعلومات المضلله اذ
تنص على وجه الخصوص بوجوب ازاله المحتوى
غير القانوني وحظر الاعلانات التي تستهدف
القاصرين وبفرض غرامات تصل الى سته في
المئه من حجم الاعمال على المنصات التي لا
تمت كل هذه القواعد
الاتحاد الاوروبي يعتبر المدونه بمثابه
ميثاق لمكافحه المعلومات المضلله في
الفضاء الالكتروني حيث وقع عليه ما يقرب
من 30 موقعا من بينها مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي الكبرى مثل ميته وتويتر الى
جانب جوجل ومايكروسوفت التهديد بالحظر لم
يكن الاول على لسان جروفا فقد سبقها الى
ذلك الوزير الفرنسي المفوض للشؤون الرقميه
الا ان الاخير اعرب عن قلقه بشان التنظيم
الاوروبي المفرط في مجال الذكاء الاصطناعي
في المستقبل معتبرا موقف البرلمان
الاوروبي مبالغا فيه لكونه يفرض التزامات
تدقيق والتزامات شفافيه مفرطه بالنسبه
لهذا النوع من النماذج وبين التهديد
بالحظر وتطبيقه قرابه الثلاثه اشهر امام
الطائر الازرق للتغريد في السماء
الاوروبيه تغريد ان سكت سيؤثر على نقاشات
الراي العام بحسب الوزير الفرنسي لكن الم
علومات المضلله تهديد للديمقراطيه
الاوروبيه
[موسيقى]
اعلنت شركه ابل عن سماعه راس للواقع
المعزز تسمى ابل فيجن برو والتي تمزج بحسب
الشركه بين العالم الحقيقي والرقمي وقال
الرئيس التنفيذي تيم كوك عن الجهاز الذي
يبدو كانه زوج من نظارات التزلج قال انه
يتم التحكم في السماعه بالعينين واليدين
والصوت وبحسب مراجعات المختصين الذين
اطلعوا على هذا المنتج فان سماعه يتوفر
فيها كل التطبيقات المتاحه على اجهزه ابل
المختلفه وتتيح التواصل ومتابعه المقاطع
المرئيه والعديد من المهام الذكيه الاخرى
من كاليفورنيا ينضم الينا عبد الله سبع
المحرر التقني في عربيه عبد الله اهلا بك
معنا منتج جديد لابل ماذا نعرف عنه ما هي
تفاصيله ما هو الجيد بهذا المنتج واذا كان
هناك من سيئات
اول شيء يعطيكم العافيه على هذا الاستضافه
نظاره ابل الجديده هي شيء مختلف قد تكون
مشجعه للمستخدمين هذه التقنيه مع عيب بسيط
فيها وهي السعر المرتفع نتكلم عن
300099 دولار النظاره الجديده من قبل هي
راح تقدم تجربه جديده للمستخدم هي نظاره
تعتمد على الوراق الممزوج وايضا مثل
الكمبيوتر انت قادر تستخدمها تخيل انك
قادر تلبس نظاره وتشوف الناس اللي حولك
وتحط تطبيقات حولك وتسوي شغلك فتخيل انك
انت في الدوام قادر انك تحط النظاره
وتلبسها وبعدها تبدا تسوي اعمالك اليوميه
لو لفيت يمين انت قادر تشوف
الاكسل لو لفيت يسارا انت قادر تشوف
البوربوينت وطلعته قدامك انت قادر تشوف
برنامج المونتاج اذا انت قاعد تمنتج
اي حد عمليه هذه النظاره يعني انه من
الممكن ان تكون معقده وخاصه للشخص الذي
يعمل مثلا هل هي حقيقه عمليه مفيده
في لازم نعرف معلومه اغلب المستخدمين
النظارات الواقع الافتراضي او الواقع
المعزز دائما بعضهم يحس بمشاكل دوخه
استخدام النظاره هذا الموضوع احنا قادرين
نتاكد منه في نظاره ابل لكن اتوقع بسبب
انها تعتمد على الواقع الممزوج واني قادر
تشوف الناس اللي حولك وقد تتفاعل مع الناس
اللي حولك والتطبيقات تكون موجوده في
العالم اللي حولك هذا شيء جدا مختلف طبعا
عنها وشو هي كمبيوتر انت قابل انك تلبسه
وتتحكم فيه بالعين تتحكم فيه بالاصابع
والتحكم فيه بالاوامر الصوتيه فانت ما انت
محدود الان في شاشه انت قادر تستخدم هذا
الكمبيوتر في البيئه المحيطه اللي حولك ما
في شاشه راح تحدك طبعا في نقطه ايضا
تتطرقوا عنها في المؤتمر تخيلي انه انت
قادر تستغني عن شاشات اللي موجوده عندك في
البيت قد تكون شاشات التلفاز من الماضي
بسبب النظارات القابله للارتداء لانك انت
قادر تشوف فيلم مسلسل برنامج بالتلفزيوني
من خلال النظ اره بالمساحه اللي انت
تشوفها بدقه جدا عاليه توازي دقه الفوركيه
طبعا نفسها قاعده تستخدمها في الاجتماعات
طبعا هي نظاره انت قادر تلتديها في
الاجتماعات وغيرها لكن الناس اللي تلبس
النظارات الطبيه
الناس اللي تلبس نظارات طبيه انا قادر
اعطيكم خبر سعيد لكم قادر انك تحط عدسات
طبيه داخلها تدعم العدسات هذه حتى تقدر
تستخدمها بشكل مريح جدا طبعا للمعلوميه هي
ما فيها بطاريه فوزنها ما راح يكون ثقيل
على المستخدم بشكل كبير هي فيها سلك انت
توصل البطاريه تحطها في جيبك ما في تفاصيل
عن كم عمر البطاريه راح يكون معك كم راح
تستمر معاك النظاره هذه التفاصيل حتى الان
ما هي واضحه عندنا لكن هي راح تكون معتمده
على معالج افضل الام تو حتى تعطيك تجربه
جدا جديده تحاول لانها تدخل مجالات جديده
وتسوي شغلات
رهيبه هل من منافس لهذه النظاره عبد الله
لانه يقال بانه منافساتها متى يعني كويستو
هي كانت منافس لمثل هذه النظاره هل هذا
صحيح
مايكروسوفت عندها نظارات نافس ابل في هذا
المجال كمان عندك ميته عندها نظاره نافس
ابل في هذا المجال لكن يبدو ان ابل قاعد
تاخذ المنافسه الى بعد اخر بسبب انها
اطلقتك كمبيوتر متكامل قابل الارتداء قادر
تستفيد منه وتستخدمه وكمان قادر انك
تتكامل مع اجهزه المايك تخيل انك انت قادر
تستخدم اجهزه المايك وتستفيد من الشاشه
وتطلع البرنامج من المايك وتسوي زي الدمج
ما بين النظارات وتستخدم برامج المونتاج
يعني فيها قدرات صراحه جدا رهيبه لدرجه
انه راح يكون فيها متجر تطبيقات خاص فيها
فراح يكون فيها كميه تطبيقات مختلفه قادر
انك تستخدمها وتستفيد منها طب هل هناك
مقاسات مثلا للاطفال ومقاسات للكبار ام هي
نظاره مقاس واحد والى اي حد ايضا الاطفال
من الممكن ان يستفيدوا من هذه النظاره
وحقيقه هذه المشكله ان الاطفال بالدنياها
وهي بهالغلا ههه
ما اتوقع ان الاصدار هذا موجه للاطفال هي
موجه للاشخاص البالغين خاصه مقاس النظاره
شوي جدا كبير فهيجي بمقراص موحد ما هي
موجهه للاطفال وفي البدايه اتوقع انها
موجهه للمطورين بشكل جدا كبير للاستخدامات
الخاصه فيهم بعدها تبدا تستخدم في مجالات
العمل والدوامات بعدها ممكن تدخل في
المجال الطبي بعدها يمكن تدخل بشكل كبير
للمصممين لان المصمم قادر يحط التصاميم
قدامه وقادر يستفيد منها ويستخدمها
ويتفاعل معها بشكل جدا كبير الطبيب قادر
يشوف الحالات قدامه ويتفاعل معاها
فالنظاره هذه راح تغير شيء جدا كبير قد
تكون في البدايه هي غير موجهه للمستخدمين
لانه لاحظوا ان استخدمت مفرد
هي نظاره احترافيه هل ممكن نشوف مستقبل
النظاره فيجن لايت فيجن عاديه فيجن من دون
برو وتكون سعرها منخفض اتوقع هذا الموضوع
قابل للتطبيق في المستقبل وممكن يشوف هذا
الشيء السنه القادمه خاصه راح تطلق
نظارتها ترى بدايه السنه القادمه ما حددوا
شهر قد يكون الربع الاول من السنه القادمه
قد يكون الربع الثاني لكن اتوقع انها تكون
في الربع الاول شكرا لك من كاليفورنيا
في العربيه
يتنافس
مرشحين ومرشحه في سباق انتخابات مجلس
الامه الكويتي بعد حل مجلس 2020 وابطال
لمجلس 20 22 اتابع
السادس من يونيو هو اليوم الذي تترقبه
الكويت من اجل اختياري 50 نائبا يمثلها
تحت قبه عبد الله السالم يترشح للسباق
انتخابات مجلس الامه 2023
ومرشحه
وزاره العدل خصصت
759 لجنه انتخابيه بعدما جهزت وزاره
التربيه
وثمانيه عشره مدرسه وحولتها لمركز اقتراح
يتوجه اليها نحو
794 الف ناخب وناخبه لاختيار نائب واحد في
دائرتهم المسجلين فيها
الكويت ومصلحه شعبها فوق اي اعتبار هذا
ابرز الشعارات المرشحين الذين حاولوا
التقرب من الناخبين بشعاراتهم وندواتهم
الانتخابيه التي ناقشوا فيها مطالب الشعبي
واسباب تاخر تحقيقها في المجالس السابقه
الا ان الترقب الاكبر يبقى على استمراريه
المجلس وعمل السلطتين التنفيذيه
والتشريعيه مع بعضهما من الكويت شاهد
المتروك العربيه
في مشهد غير اعتيادي شهدت مدينه الباحه
جنوب غرب السعوديه تساقطا للثلوج رغم
اقتراب موسم الصيف الحار نتابع
[موسيقى]
ختاما نذكر بعناوين اخبار الساعه
مع هجمات اوكرانيا تقر بخساره منطقه في
بخموت وانفصال يودونيتس يركزون صعوبه
الموقف
اشتباكات محتدمه في كتب والجنينه في
دارفور والسلطات المحليه تحذر من كارثه
بعد الفوز بالانتخابات تعيينات اردوغان
تكشف عن تراجع في سياسات اقتصاديه تسببت
في انهيار الليره والاتحاد الاوروبي يحذر
من خطوره سياسه للذكاء الاصطناعي ويتهم
تويتر بعدم التعب الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات